bolsonaro de regreso a Brasil luego de
haber llegado a Estados Unidos el 31 de
diciembre en plena víspera de la
investidura presidencial de su rival de
izquierda Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el
expresidente de Brasil dijo inicialmente
a la prensa que quería disfrutar como un
turista más en Estados Unidos llegó a
territorio norteamericano con una visa
diplomática de un mes que caducó el 31
de enero y sus abogados comentaron con
la prensa brasileña que el mandatario
había solicitado una visa de turista
para extender su estadía y así poder
estar hasta por un mínimo de seis meses
sin embargo en entrevista con The Wall
Street journal el presidente aseguró que
podría regresar a Brasil en marzo Tengo
la intención de regresar a Brasil en las
semanas que vienen mi objetivo es
convertirme en el jefe de la oposición
quiero defenderme contra las acusaciones
de golpe de estado Yo no estuve ahí y
ellos quieren responsabilizarme de ello
de regreso a su país le esperan Las
investigaciones judiciales por un lado
acusaciones por presuntamente alentar
protestas antidemocráticas que
terminaron en el asalto a edificios
gubernamentales por fanáticos
bolsonaristas en la capital brasileña en
el tribunal electoral se están
tramitando 16 demandas relacionadas con
su campaña presidencial del año pasado a
las que se le suman las indagaciones por
su presunto mal manejo de la pandemia
del covid 19 y la difusión de noticias
falsas durante el confinamiento delitos
que bolsonaron niega sin el amparo que
le otorgaba la presidencia y sin
inmunidad judicial si se demuestran las
acusaciones bolsonaro estaría en amenaza
de ser enjuiciado potencialmente
encarcelado o podría quedar inhabilitado
para postularse a elecciones durante por
lo menos ocho años